Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. In this episode, we're going to talk about Veterans Mental Health. Having just marked Veterans Day earlier this month, it's a good time to discuss the mental health challenges that many veterans deal with, some of the latest psychological research into their care, and the complexities of modern warfare and its effect on veterans. I'm joined today by Dr. Rajiv Ramchand, a fellow at the Bob Woodrow Foundation, who researches the prevalence, prevention, and treatment of mental health and substance use disorders in veterans and other populations, and Terry Tenelian, a senior behavioral scientist at Rand Corporation,
您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。在本期节目中，我们将讨论退伍军人的心理健康。本月初我们刚刚纪念了退伍军人节，现在正是讨论许多退伍军人所面临的心理健康挑战、关于他们护理的最新心理学研究，以及现代战争的复杂性及其对退伍军人影响的好时机。今天做客节目的有鲍勃·伍德罗基金会的研究员拉吉夫·拉姆钱德博士，他研究退伍军人及其他人群中心理健康和药物滥用障碍的流行率、预防及治疗；还有兰德公司的资深行为科学家特里·特内利安，
who researches military and veterans health policy, military suicide, and the psychological effects of combat and terrorism. Thank you both so much for joining us today. Thank you for having us. Yes, thank you. So first I want to start on. off by talking about what are some of the most pressing mental health issues that veterans face today? I can get us started, sure. So, you know, we need to recognize there are about 19 million veterans living
她研究军事和退伍军人健康政策、军人自杀以及战斗和恐怖主义带来的心理影响。非常感谢两位今天能参加我们的节目。谢谢邀请。是的，谢谢。那么首先，我想从讨论当今退伍军人面临的最紧迫的心理健康问题开始。我可以先来开个头，没问题。你知道，我们需要认识到，目前在美国生活着大约1900万退伍军人，
in the United States today, and it's a very diverse population. It's becoming increasingly diverse, as we see more and more women who've served in uniform. And according to national data, we know that about 20% of veterans have a mental health problem. And this can include a range of conditions, such as post-traumatic stress disorder, but also depression, bipolar disorder, and substance use problems. We see that the rates of these conditions do vary by gender and age, particularly associated with the era of service of those veterans. So our veterans are facing a wide array of mental health challenges. Do you want to ask anything, Rijee? Sure.
这是一个非常多元化的群体。随着越来越多的女性穿上军装服役，这个群体正变得日益多元化。根据国家数据，我们知道大约20%的退伍军人患有心理健康问题。这可能包括一系列疾病，如创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），也包括抑郁症、双相情感障碍和药物滥用问题。我们发现，这些疾病的发病率确实因性别和年龄而异，特别是与退伍军人的服役时期有关。所以我们的退伍军人正面临着广泛的心理健康挑战。拉吉夫，你想补充点什么吗？当然。
I would just echo what Terry was saying that a lot of times we think of when we talk about veterans, the most recent, cadre of veterans, what we would refer to as the post-9-11 veterans. But as Terry mentioned, especially as we have veterans from the first Gulf War, Vietnam, Korea, aging, I think that we're going to see this bulk, as we are in American society at large, of mental health challenges associated with aging and the veteran population. We'll see that continue. And I think that it's just important for us to keep an eye on those older veterans. I want to zero in a bit more on a post-traumatic stress disorder. Are certain people more prone to having that happen to them when they return from more? So I can take that one. We have seen the most significant predictor of post-traumatic
我想附和特里刚才所说的，很多时候当我们谈论退伍军人时，我们想到的是最近的一批退伍军人，也就是我们所说的“9·11”事件后的退伍军人。但正如特里所提到的，特别是随着第一次海湾战争、越南战争、朝鲜战争的退伍军人逐渐老龄化，我认为我们将看到，正如我们在整个美国社会所看到的那样，与老龄化相关的心理健康挑战在退伍军人群体中也会出现。我们将看到这种情况持续下去。我认为我们关注那些年长的退伍军人非常重要。我想更深入地探讨一下创伤后应激障碍。某些人在从战场归来后是否更容易患上这种疾病？这个问题我来回答。我们已经看到，在各项研究和样本中，创伤后应激障碍最显著的预测因素是
stress disorder across studies and across samples is exposure to combat. So when people deploy, they have a variety of different experiences that depends on where they're stationed, the security climate of the region, the more intense combat exposure is consistently linked to suicide. Anything kind of above and beyond that might be a little bit here and there, but I'll turn it over to Terry to add more color if she wants. Sure. Well, we know that there are certain characteristics that are associated with those who may experience more combat related traumas and exposures based upon the service that they served in as well as the time period that they were deployed. But as Rajiv said, it really,
暴露于战斗中。因此，当人们被部署时，他们会根据驻扎地点、该地区的安全环境经历各种不同的体验，更强烈的战斗暴露始终与自杀倾向相关。除此之外的任何因素可能影响较小，但我会把话语权交给特里，如果她想补充更多细节的话。当然。嗯，我们知道，某些特征与那些可能经历更多战斗相关创伤和暴露的人有关，这取决于他们服役的军种以及他们被部署的时间段。但正如拉吉夫所说，实际上，
the most significant predictor is the number of combat traumas and individual experiences while they're deployed. And that may be irrespective of the time that they are in theater of the number of deployments they've had, but the number of experience that they've had during any one given deployment. What treatment options are available for veterans with post-traumatic stress disorder? So there are a number of treatments that are available, but we also know that research suggests that there are some particular treatments that have been proven to be very efficacious in reducing the symptoms of post-traumatic stress disorder. The guidelines that DOD and the Department of Veterans Affairs have released kind of highlight some of these evidence-based therapies and recommend that veterans be offered one of them as a first-line treatment option. These often focus on trying to process and confront the trauma that is the source of the problems for veterans. There are three in particular that are recommended for treating PTSD, prolonged exposure, trauma-focused cognitive processing therapy, and EMDR, which is another form of trauma-focused psychotherapy.
最重要的预测因素是他们在部署期间经历的战斗创伤次数和个人体验。这可能与他们在战区的时间长短、部署次数无关，而是与他们在任何一次特定部署期间所经历的次数有关。退伍军人有哪些治疗创伤后应激障碍的方案？目前有多种治疗方法，但我们也知道，研究表明，有一些特定的治疗方法已被证明在减轻创伤后应激障碍症状方面非常有效。国防部和退伍军人事务部发布的指南强调了其中一些循证疗法，并建议将其中一种作为退伍军人的一线治疗方案。这些疗法通常侧重于尝试处理和面对作为退伍军人问题根源的创伤。特别推荐三种治疗PTSD的方法：持续暴露疗法、创伤聚焦认知处理疗法，以及EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工），这是另一种形式的创伤聚焦心理治疗。
That's EMDR has gotten a lot of publicity lately. Can you explain a little more about what that is and how that would help a veteran? I can try. I am not a clinician, and we know that the evidence that has been generated for EMDR has shown that it's worked well in civilian populations, but we do not have as much data on how efficiation it is for veterans. but it is an approach that tries to help individuals process and make sense of their trauma by calling the trauma to mind while they pay attention to a back and forth movement or sound, such as a finger moving back and forth. So again, I'm not a clinician, but I know that this is a treatment that is being utilized, and we're hopeful that we'll see more data on how effective it is for treating veterans with PTSD. And Terry, can you explain more about what exposure therapy is?
EMDR最近受到了很多关注。你能多解释一下它是什么，以及它如何帮助退伍军人吗？我可以试着解释一下。我不是临床医生，我们知道针对EMDR的研究证据表明它在平民群体中效果良好，但我们对于它对退伍军人的有效性还没有足够多的数据。但它是一种试图通过让个体在回忆创伤的同时，关注来回移动的物体或声音（例如手指来回移动）来帮助他们处理和理解创伤的方法。所以再次声明，我不是临床医生，但我知道这是一种正在被使用的治疗方法，我们希望未来能看到更多关于它在治疗患有PTSD的退伍军人方面有效性的数据。特里，你能多解释一下什么是暴露疗法吗？
Sure. Well, prolonged exposure therapy is a protocol-based treatment approach that teaches an individual to gain control of their trauma by facing the negative feelings. And it often involves talking about the trauma with a therapist and doing some of the things that you once avoided. So you're increasingly exposed to things that you've avoided and try to gain control over the situations and your responses to them. And so when members of the military are discharged,
当然。持续暴露疗法是一种基于方案的治疗方法，它教导个体通过面对负面情绪来获得对创伤的控制。它通常涉及与治疗师谈论创伤，并做一些你曾经回避的事情。因此，你会被逐渐暴露在那些你曾经回避的事物中，并试图获得对这些情况及其反应的控制。那么，当军人退伍时，
are they given information about the resources that are available to them through Veterans Affairs, through other resources? I can start with this, and then maybe Rajiv can add, it's important to reflect that the past 18 years have seen some pretty dramatic changes in how the Department of Defense kind of exposes and encourages service members to gain access
他们是否会获得关于退伍军人事务部或其他资源所提供信息的渠道？我可以先从这一点开始，然后拉吉夫或许可以补充。重要的是要反思，过去18年里，国防部在如何向军人展示并鼓励他们获得行为健康护理方面发生了相当巨大的变化。
to behavioral health care. And so over time, they've really changed the types of support that were available to troops in theater. But they've also introduced a number of programs that have helped raise awareness about the resources and treatment options that are available when the troops come home, but also as they transition out of the military. There's been an increased effort to make service members more aware of the services that are available, available to them from the Department of Veterans Affairs and the options that they can pursue through the Veterans Health Administration. We've also seen a proliferation of support programs and treatment facilities in the non-governmental sector that have been funded largely in the
随着时间的推移，他们确实改变了在战区为部队提供的支持类型。但他们也推出了一系列项目，帮助提高人们对部队回家后以及退伍过渡期可获得的资源和治疗方案的认识。人们越来越努力地让军人了解退伍军人事务部为他们提供的服务，以及他们可以通过退伍军人健康管理局寻求的选择。我们还看到非政府部门涌现了大量支持项目和治疗设施，这些设施主要由慈善部门资助，旨在建立额外的卓越中心或诊所，提供门诊甚至强化门诊服务，以治疗退伍军人的心理健康问题。
philanthropic sector to create additional centers of excellence or clinics that offer outpatient or even intensive outpatient services to treat veterans' with mental health problems. Yeah, and I would just say, you know, to add upon Tari's, that that transition period, we know, is a really important period to engage veterans, to make sure that they're aware of their benefits, their eligibility, what's available. But it also assumes that, you know, they're going, they're becoming veterans and they're going through a transition status and they'll know everything and they'll retain everything.
是的，我想补充一点，正如特里所说，我们知道过渡期是让退伍军人参与进来的一个非常重要的时期，要确保他们了解自己的福利、资格以及可用的资源。但这同时也假设他们知道自己正在成为退伍军人，正在经历过渡状态，并且他们会知道一切、记住一切。
And it's a lot of information to process. And, you know, it's a different time. they're leaving one career and going to a completely different culture and a different career. And I think that it's just incumbent upon us as a society to keep reminding veterans what's available because even their needs for treatment might evolve over time. They might not need it at that immediate time or they might think they might not need it. But six months down the road, a year down the road, two years down the road, they might decide that then it's time for treatment. And we need to make sure that they know at those various junctures that treatment options are available for them.
要处理的信息量非常大。而且，这是一个不同的时期，他们正在离开一个职业，进入一个完全不同的文化和职业。我认为，作为社会，我们有责任不断提醒退伍军人有哪些资源可用，因为即使是他们的治疗需求也可能随时间而演变。他们可能在当时不需要，或者认为自己不需要。但六个月后、一年后、两年后，他们可能会决定是时候接受治疗了。我们需要确保他们在这些不同的节点都知道有治疗方案可供选择。
Yeah, that's a really critical point. I think that there's so much focus on the military to civilian transition. And we think that there's this one-time opportunity to educate service members about the options that will be available. But not only is it an overwhelming time, but they may find and recognize a need for it five, 10 years. later. And so we need to make sure that we're continually doing education and outreach to inform veterans and their family members about the services that they may be eligible for and that could benefit them. Terry, can you talk about some of the notable differences in mental health among veterans of different generations? We talked before about the differences between Vietnam veterans
是的，这是一个非常关键的观点。我认为人们太关注从军队到平民的过渡了。我们认为只有一次机会来教育军人关于未来可用的选择。但这不仅是一个令人不知所措的时期，而且他们可能在五年、十年后才发现并意识到这种需求。因此，我们需要确保不断进行教育和外展工作，告知退伍军人及其家人他们可能有资格获得哪些服务，以及哪些服务能让他们受益。特里，你能谈谈不同代际退伍军人在心理健康方面的一些显著差异吗？我们之前谈到了越南战争退伍军人、
to Desert Storm veterans to Veterans of the Wars in Iraq and Afghanistan. Can you elaborate on that a bit more? Sure. We know that the rates of post-traumatic stress disorder in terms of the point and time estimates of prevalence among these cohorts of veterans do vary, but it's important to keep in mind that the context for how these men and women deployed are also very different. Vietnam-era veterans, you know, served in the era of the draft. And so, you know, the all-volunteer force is a much different context. At the same time, our understanding of post-traumatic stress disorder has really evolved. And we've learned what we know currently today about identifying and diagnosing PTSD as well as treating it really on the backs of the Vietnam-era veterans. And so while
沙漠风暴退伍军人以及伊拉克和阿富汗战争退伍军人之间的差异。你能详细说明一下吗？当然。我们知道，在这些退伍军人群体中，创伤后应激障碍的患病率在不同时间点的估计值确实有所不同，但重要的是要记住，这些男女军人被部署时的背景也非常不同。越南战争时期的退伍军人是在征兵制时代服役的。所以，全志愿兵役制是一个非常不同的背景。与此同时，我们对创伤后应激障碍的理解确实已经演变。我们目前所知的关于识别和诊断PTSD以及治疗它的知识，实际上是建立在越南战争时期退伍军人的基础之上的。所以虽然
we can think about the rates of prevalence and even lifetime prevalence of PTSD. It's important to take into consideration some of those differences and nuances. Studies have shown that roughly between 11 and 20 percent of post-9-11 veterans experience PTSD at any given point in time. For Gulf War illness or Gulf War I veterans, that's about 12 percent. But again, that population hasn't been systematically assessed as much as we've done with the Vietnam era population where we see, you know, a point in time prevalence of about 15% for post-traumatic stress disorder and 30% for lifetime prevalence of PTSD. And so changes and differences in how we screen for and diagnose PTSD certainly contribute to those differences. but also our awareness and understanding of how to treat them offer hope for each of these veterans in terms of potential opportunities for recovery.
我们可以考虑PTSD的患病率甚至终身患病率，但考虑这些差异和细微差别非常重要。研究表明，大约11%到20%的“9·11”后退伍军人在任何特定时间点都患有PTSD。对于海湾战争或第一次海湾战争的退伍军人，这一比例约为12%。但同样，该群体尚未像我们对越南战争时期群体那样进行过系统的评估，我们在越南战争时期群体中看到PTSD的现患率约为15%，终身患病率约为30%。因此，我们筛查和诊断PTSD方式的变化和差异确实导致了这些不同，但我们对如何治疗他们的认识和理解也为每一位退伍军人提供了康复机会的希望。
And I would just add to that that I think when we're talking about these different generations of veterans, we have to think about their cultural attitudes. And I don't want to claim that stigma is no longer an issue, but certainly the younger generation of veterans has been having more open discussions about mental health. There's been more of a push, a contemporaneous push, to encourage those in need to seek treatment. And that wasn't the case necessarily among people
我还要补充一点，我认为当我们谈论这些不同代际的退伍军人时，我们必须考虑他们的文化态度。我不想声称污名化不再是一个问题，但年轻一代的退伍军人确实在更公开地讨论心理健康。现在有更多的推动力，一种当代的推动力，鼓励有需要的人寻求治疗。而在从其他战争中归来的人群中，情况未必如此。
who were returning from other wars. And so thinking of the cultural differences, I think, about what they think about mental health treatment, we might need different strategies to target some of the older veterans who may have been experiencing and really suffering from PTSD symptoms for really long periods of time, but still could benefit from treatment regardless of the duration from when it occurred. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, if you think about the context of support that these veterans faced upon returning home and the difference is there, not just in over.
因此，考虑到关于心理健康治疗的文化差异，我们可能需要不同的策略来针对那些年长的退伍军人，他们可能长期以来一直经历并深受PTSD症状的折磨，但无论距离创伤发生的时间有多久，他们仍然可以从治疗中受益。是的，绝对是这样。我的意思是，如果你考虑到这些退伍军人回家后所面临的支持环境，以及其中的差异，不仅仅是克服寻求治疗的障碍并认识到他们面临挑战，而且他们回家时受到邻居的欢迎程度，以及这如何导致羞耻感和寻求帮助的意愿，我认为这也是需要考虑的重要因素。
overcoming some of the barriers to seek treatment and kind of recognize that they have challenges, but how they were embraced by, you know, their neighbors when they returned home and how that can contribute to shame and willingness to raise your hand and get help, I think is also important to consider. Absolutely. It's very important to note that veterans who came back from World War II were received very differently from Vietnam veterans. And do you think that the reception of veterans today is better than it was for Vietnam era veterans? You know, it was a very charged political climate when
绝对是。非常重要的一点是，二战归来的退伍军人与越南战争退伍军人受到的待遇截然不同。你认为今天退伍军人受到的接待比越南战争时期更好吗？你知道，当越南战争退伍军人归来时，政治气候非常紧张。但与此同时，军人与平民社会的融合程度更高。所以更多的非退伍军人平民认识退伍军人，他们融合得更好。随着我们废除了征兵制，这一代新的退伍军人，正如特里刚才所说，得到了很多支持，涌现了许多非政府组织，他们正在进行外展、研究并欢迎退伍军人回家。但与此同时，我们正处于历史上非退伍军人与退伍军人之间隔阂最大的时期。平民社会中有许多非退伍军人从未见过退伍军人，退伍军人不在他们的社交圈内。
Vietnam vets were returning. But at the same time, there was more of an integration of military personnel with the civilian society. So more civilians who are non-veterans, new veterans, and they were kind of more integrated. As we've gotten rid of the draft and this new generation of veterans, there's been a lot of support and outpouring of, as Terry was talking about earlier, non-governmental organizations that are conducting outreach and researching and welcoming veterans back. But at the same time, we're at a point in our history with the biggest separation between non-veterans and veterans. There are many non-veterans in civilian society who've never met a veteran who veterans are not in their social circle.
所以我认为这是一个有趣的问题，因为你有这两种动态在同时发生。是的，绝对是。拉吉夫，早些时候我们交谈时，你提到关于PTSD，并不是每一位退伍军人在结束服役回来后都患有创伤后应激障碍，但一个人本质上不能在不以某种方式发生改变的情况下离开军队。你能多解释一下吗？嗯，我的意思是，我认为这在人类发展的本质上就是这样，我们都会经历一些体验，它们会改变我们。
So that's why I think it's an interesting question because you have these two kind of dynamics happening concurrently. Yeah, absolutely. And Rajiv, earlier when we spoke, you mentioned how with PTSD, you know, not every single veteran has post-traumatic stress disorder when they come back from when they finish their military service. but that a person cannot essentially, you said, leave the service without being changed in some way or the other. Can you explain that a little bit more? Well, I mean, I think it's just kind of developmentally in human nature that we all go through experiences and, you know, they change us.
它们会影响我们。而且，我认为我们一直专注于PTSD和一些负面的心理健康后果，或者说一些心理健康挑战。但对于许多人来说，他们学到了很多，许多退伍军人能够利用并发展出他们原本不会拥有的技能。他们成为了领导者。他们发展出了非常出色的领导素质，这些素质并没有得到很好的记录。所以我认为你的问题可以从很多方面来回答。但现在，我真的在思考，特别是在退伍军人节到来之际，他们所学到的所有东西，以及他们从经历中
They kind of influence us. And, you know, I think that we've been focusing, you know, on PTSD and some of the, you know, negative mental health consequences, if you will, or some of the mental health challenges. But for many people, they've learned, you know, many veterans have been able to use and develop skills that they otherwise wouldn't have. They've become leaders. They've developed really great leadership qualities that haven't been as well documented. So I think there's many ways to take your question. But right now, you know, I'm really thinking about, especially as Veterans Day, is upon us really kind of all the things that they've learned and all the ways that they've
潜在的成长。我认为我们需要认识到，退伍军人确实可以为社会做出独特的贡献，我们需要充分利用这一点。绝对是。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，如果你认可他们对公共服务的奉献，以及他们愿意挺身而出保卫国家，通过冒着生命危险为社会做出贡献，那种仆人式领导力是一种关键品质，它显现出来并需要像我们关注那些挣扎的人一样受到重视和认可。我们需要认识到我们所有退伍军人的价值和贡献。让我们转向当今我国非常关注的一个领域，
potentially grown from their experience. And I think that we need to recognize, you know, that veterans have really unique contributions that they can offer to society that we really need to capitalize on. Absolutely. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, I think if you recognize their dedication to public service and, you know, their willingness to raise their hand and defend our nation and contribute to society by, you know, putting their own lives on the line, you know, that servant leadership is a key quality that comes through and needs to be valued and recognized as much as we need to pay attention to those who struggle. We need to recognize the value and contribution that all of our veterans make. Let's move on to an area of large
那就是退伍军人的自杀问题。根据我找到的一份政府估计，每天有17名退伍军人死于自杀。男性退伍军人死于自杀的可能性是未服役者的1.5倍。女性退伍军人的情况更糟，她们死于自杀的可能性是未服役者的2.2倍。显然，这表明在减少这些数字方面还有更多工作要做。你能解释一下什么治疗方法对有自杀倾向的退伍军人有效，以及你看到了哪些差距吗？特里，我们从你开始好吗？嗯，这些都是很好的问题。我认为我们必须了解退伍军人面临的风险和挑战，并提供高质量的心理健康服务，这是全面自杀预防方法的关键组成部分。而且，虽然我们一直在努力了解风险因素和保护因素，但我们确实知道，提供高质量的心理健康服务是减少自杀行为和自杀风险的一种非常重要且有效的方法。因此，确保我们减少护理障碍并促进使用我所谈到的这些循证疗法，对于确保我们能够降低退伍军人的自杀风险至关重要。与此同时，我们知道减少自杀的另一种有效方法是手段限制，
concern in our country today, and that's suicide among veterans. According to a government estimate, I found, there's 17 veterans who die by suicide every single day. And male veterans were 1.5 more times more likely to die by suicide than people who did not serve. And female veterans fared even worse as they were 2.2 times more likely to die by suicide than those who didn't serve. Clearly, this shows there's more that needs to be done to reduce these numbers. Can you explain what treatment works for veterans contemplating suicide and what gaps you see. Why don't we start with you, Terry? Well, these are great questions. And I think we have to understand, you know, a little bit about the risk and challenges that veterans face and providing access to high quality mental health
并使环境更安全。对于退伍军人来说，这意味着真正专注于讨论枪支安全，并思考有助于解决退伍军人枪支获取和存储问题的政策，因为他们可能处于自杀风险中。如果我们想在自杀问题上取得进展，这两个领域确实需要关注。但还有其他领域。我很乐意听听拉吉夫提供一些想法，因为我知道这也是他一直在研究的领域。是的，特里所说的是完全正确的。关于你提出的治疗方案和差距的问题，是我经常思考的事情。
services as a key component of a comprehensive suicide prevention approach. And, you know, while we are always striving to understand the risk factors and the protective factors, you know, we do know that access and delivery of high quality mental health services is a very important and effective means of reducing suicidal behavior and suicidal risk for veterans. And so ensuring that we reduce the barriers to care and promote the use of these evidence-based therapies that I talked about will be critically important for making sure that we can reduce risk of suicide for veterans. At the same time that we know another effective means of reducing suicide is means restriction
我们知道，在普通人群中，50%死于自杀的人正在接受治疗。他们已经在接受心理健康治疗了。所以特里关于提供循证和高质量治疗的观点非常重要。据我所知，可以称之为有三到四种治疗方法已经过实证检验，可以减少自杀企图和自杀倾向。它们是辩证行为疗法、认知行为疗法（格雷格·布朗开发的针对自杀的特定版本）、安全计划。格雷格·布朗、芭芭拉·斯坦利以及克雷格·布莱恩都思考并发表过关于安全计划要素的文章，还有大卫·乔布的自杀倾向管理协作评估（CAMS）。所以这四种是非常高质量的治疗方法，而且，有些人认为安全计划也是一种治疗。但这些确实是迄今为止证据最充分的。我认为挑战之一是将这些治疗方法推广到社区提供者手中，以便当有人进来并接受自杀评估时（他们应该常规进行），提供者有能力直接治疗该人的自杀倾向。而这正是这些治疗方法所提供的。所以这非常关键。
and making the environment safer. And for veterans, this means really focusing in and discussing firearm safety and thinking through policies that can help address. access to firearms and storage of firearms for veterans who may be at risk of suicide. And those really are two big important areas that require attention if we're going to move the needle on suicide. But there are others as well. And I'd love to hear Rajiv provide some thoughts as this is an area that I know that he's been studying as well. Yeah. So what Terry said is absolutely correct. In terms of your question about what are the treatment options and what are the gaps is something that I think about a lot.
但除此之外，还有很多其他事情，你知道，除了治疗之外。特里所谈到的关于更安全的环境、枪支存储政策等，也绝对是至关重要的。而且，正如我们刚才所谈到的，当我们思考退伍军人自杀时，我们必须记住，很多自杀，你知道，在退伍军人中，2017年有超过6000名退伍军人死亡。其中大部分，大部分是50岁以上的人。你知道，他们是中年人。
We know that 50% of those who die by suicide are in treatment in the general population. They're already in mental health treatment. So Terry's point about delivery of evidence-based and high-quality treatment is really important. And to my knowledge, you could call it three to four treatments that have been empirically tested to reduce suicide. attempts and suicidality. And those are dialectical behavioral therapy, cognitive behavioral therapy, a specific version for suicide that Greg Brown developed safety planning. And there's elements of safety plan that both Greg Brown and Barbara Stanley, as well as Craig Bryan, have thought about and published on, as well as David Job's collaborative assessment for the manage of suicidality
他们不是“9·11”后的退伍军人。所以我们绝对必须关注“9·11”后的群体。但我们也必须记住，我们如何接触这一代年长的退伍军人，或者其他时代的退伍军人，并确保我们仍然关注他们，为他们提供高质量的护理和适合他们的方法。你提到老年群体自杀率如此之高，这真的很令人着迷。这与我们最初关于
or CAMs. So those are four really high quality. kind of treatments and, you know, the safety planning, some people consider a treatment. But those are really kind of the strongest evidence to date. And I think one of the challenges is getting these treatments out to providers in the community so that they are equipped when somebody comes in and they assess them for suicide, which they should, you know, routinely be doing, that the providers are equipped to then treat the person's suicidality directly. And that's what these treatments offer. So that's just so critical.
退伍军人老龄化是当今最重要的问题的观点相吻合。我的意思是，在普通人群中自杀，很多时候我们关注的是比率。我应该注意到，虽然“9·11”后退伍军人的比率高于非退伍军人，但“9·11”前群体的退伍军人数量要多得多。
But then, you know, there's a lot of other things as well, you know, besides treatment. And what Terry was talking about in terms of safer environments and firearm storage policies and things of that nature are absolutely critical as well. And, you know, just touching on what we were talking about earlier, you know, when we think about veteran suicide, we have to remember that a lot of the suicide, the suicide, you know, among the veterans, there's around 6,000, over 6,000 veterans who died in 2017. The bulk of those, the bulk of those were over the age of 50. You know, they're middle age.
所以这是一种风险和比率与死亡负担所在位置之间的平衡。从公共卫生角度来看，我们必须针对所有这些人群，并且必须同时考虑这两个群体。但在美国，自杀负担通常也集中在中年男性和老年男性群体中。我认为这是一个我们确实需要更多讨论的领域。为什么女性退伍军人更脆弱？我的意思是，她们的自杀率比男性退伍军人高。你知道，我不确定女性退伍军人的自杀率是否高于男性退伍军人。风险更大。所以当你观察女性时，退伍军人相对于非退伍军人的风险比男性退伍军人相对于男性非退伍军人的风险要大。但我必须仔细查看数据，看看比率是如何比较的。但话虽如此，观点很明确。这回到了特里早些时候所说的关于多元化和女性退伍军人人口增加的问题。我，你知道，迄今为止最强有力的证据表明，经历过军事性创伤或军事性创伤筛查呈阳性会增加随后自杀的风险。因此，解决军事自杀，或者军事性创伤，在我看来，可以直接影响退伍军人，尤其是女性退伍军人未来的自杀率。与此同时，对于那些已经经历过军事性创伤的女性，我们必须确保再次为她们提供这种高质量的循证护理。对于女性退伍军人，我认为文化胜任力变得更加重要。我知道特里在提供者和文化胜任力方面做了很多工作。所以也许她可以谈谈这一点。当然。我只想指出，我们知道即使在平民部门，经历过人际暴力和家庭暴力的女性也可能面临更大的自杀风险。因此，旨在减少性暴力、
They're not the post-9-11 veterans. So we have to focus on that post-9-11 group, absolutely. But we also have to keep in mind how are we reaching this older generation, or this other era of veterans and make sure that we're still keeping them in focus and offering them high-quality care and approaches that work for them. It's really fascinating that you mentioned that the older population, you're seeing rates of suicide be as high as they are. And that goes along with our very first question about,
性骚扰的干预措施和方法，确实也可以起到减少未来自杀风险的作用。所以这些努力确实非常重要。但是，当我们谈论确保获得高质量的心理健康服务，特别是针对退伍军人时，文化胜任力的作用经常被提及。这是一种理念，即提供者对退伍军人可能面临的独特经历具有文化意识或敏感性，他们不仅能说同样的语言，理解一些术语或退伍军人在军队中面临的一些文化问题，这确实有助于在提供者和退伍军人之间建立更好的治疗关系，从而使他们能够成功参与。
you're saying that aging in the veteran population is an issue of what most importance today. I mean, suicide in the general population, you know, a lot of times we focus on the rates. And I should notice, I should note that there is this, the rates are higher among post- 9-11 veterans than non-veterans, but the numbers of veterans are much higher in that pre-9-11 group, if you will.
循证治疗。因此，人们付出了很多努力来提高针对退伍军人的提供者的文化胜任力，特别是在心理健康领域，这样他们不仅能说同样的语言，还能理解并培养对他们所面临经历的敏感性和同理心。对于经历过性骚扰或性侵犯的女性，甚至实际上对于一些男性，你知道，虽然男性暴露于军事性骚扰和创伤的比率可能较低，但军队中男性更多。所以经历过军事性创伤的男性数量也很高。
So it's this kind of balance between higher risk and rates relative to kind of where the burden of mortality is. And that's a balance that from a public health approach, we have to target all of these populations and we have to think about both of those groups. But in the United States, generally the burden of suicide is also in kind of this. middle-aged men group and older men. And I think that that's a area that we really need to talk more about. And why are female veterans more vulnerable? I mean, their suicide rate was higher than those of male veterans. You know, I'm not sure if the suicide rate is higher
知道询问这些经历对于尝试理解这可能与他们当前的心理健康状况或问题有何关联，以及与他们自杀行为的风险有何关联至关重要。关于文化胜任力，我知道在少数群体中，拥有对客户有深刻理解的心理健康提供者非常重要。在这种情况下，拥有军事背景，我假设这可能非常有益，或者至少有深刻的理解。你认为今天有足够的心理学家拥有这些背景和理解吗？你知道，这些心理学家，是否有足够多的人在与退伍军人合作？嗯，这是一个很好的问题。而且，我认为重要的是要理清，这仅仅是关于拥有军事背景，还是文化胜任力可以通过接触和与该群体工作而获得。我们发现，任何即使作为平民与军事群体工作过，或在退伍军人事务部工作过的人，在评估提供者社区军事文化胜任力的标准上得分都会更高。
among female veterans and male veterans. The risk is greater. So when you look at females, veterans have a greater risk relative to non-veterans than male veterans do to male veterans. non-veterans. But I have to look carefully at the numbers to see how the rates compare. But that said, the point is well taken. And this gets back to something Terry said earlier about, you know, about kind of the diversity and the increasing, you know, population of veteran who are women. I, you know, some of the strongest evidence to date is that a lot of, that military sexual, having experienced military sexual trauma or screened positive for military sexual trauma increases risk for subsequent suicide. So addressing military suicide is going to, or military
特别是在心理健康方面，人们致力于提高心理健康治疗师的文化胜任力，比非心理健康治疗师更多。但仍然没有太多数据表明提供者的文化胜任力与临床结果挂钩。因此，理论上，这是关于这种文化胜任力有助于增强治疗关系，这对于治疗参与、保留和依从性至关重要。对治疗的依从性。因此，强调培训提供者很重要，但不仅仅是心理学家或心理健康治疗师拥有军事背景，而是他们可能接触过并与该群体工作过，并接受过关于退伍军人社区可能面临的经历的培训，以便他们提出正确的问题，倾听并建立良好的治疗关系。在进入下一个话题之前，凯特琳，我只是想强调，对于女性退伍军人，我们在研究中一次又一次地听到，认为她们不是退伍军人的假设非常强烈。所以，在退伍军人事务部设施中，当非临床人员，当办理入住手续的人员、行政支持人员假设女性是退伍军人的配偶时，这可能会让人非常反感。所以我认为这同样适用于社区提供者。我不知道我们是否知道社区提供者在多大程度上做出了这些假设。研究不一定做过，但我认为这非常关键，文化胜任力需要对退伍军人人口的多元化有理解，不要做出假设，只需思考并允许，你知道，你的内隐偏见，认识到你自己潜在的内隐偏见并纠正它。
sexual trauma is going to, in my opinion, can potentially directly impact the suicide rates down the roads of veterans and especially women veterans. At the same time, you know, for the women who've already experienced military sexual trauma, we have to ensure that they are provided, again, this high quality evidence-based care. And for women veterans, I think cultural competency becomes so much more important. And I know Terry's done a lot of work on that among providers and cultural competency. So maybe she could speak to that. Sure. I just want to note, you know, we know even in the civilian sector that women who experience interpersonal violence and domestic violence may also be at greater risk for suicide. And so interventions and approaches designed to decrease sexual violence,
是的，我想那非常重要。你说如果有人假设女性不是退伍军人，那已经为你设置了一个可能支离破碎的关系，或者引发了许多以后无济于事的不同问题。所以你说基本上在这个领域还有很多工作要做，但至少对军队有深刻的理解，并拥有这些知识对客户和关系是有益的。是的。在我的讨论中，特里确实帮助我思考了这一点。你知道，我过去认为高质量的护理，就像证据，就像你在权衡，提供者在权衡两件事：高质量护理和文化胜任力，并在两者之间权衡。特里确实说服了我，并帮助我理解，高质量护理的一部分不仅是提供循证护理，而且还要具备文化胜任力。所以它们不是两件分开的事情。它们都是高质量护理保护伞下的一部分。对。你认为总体而言，退伍军人寻求心理健康服务存在很多污名化吗？你认为今天有所减轻吗？我的意思是，总体而言，在人群中，心理健康污名化已经减少，但在退伍军人群体中，它在减少吗？还是一样？所以，你知道，我喜欢拆解“污名化”这个词，并真正地……
a sexual harassment, you know, can really also serve to decrease later risk for suicide. So those efforts are really critically important. But, you know, the role of cultural competence often comes up when we talk about ensuring access to high quality services and mental health, in particular for veterans. And it's this notion that the provider has a cultural awareness or sensitivity to the unique experiences that veterans may have faced, that they not only can speak the language and understand some of the terms or some of the kind of cultural issues that veterans faced while they're in the military that can really serve to help develop a better therapeutic rapport between the provider and the veterans so that they can successfully engage.
性骚扰，你知道，实际上也有助于降低日后的自杀风险。因此，这些努力至关重要。但是，你知道，当我们谈论确保获得高质量的心理健康服务，特别是针对退伍军人时，文化胜任力的作用经常被提及。这是一种理念，即医疗服务提供者对退伍军人可能面临的独特经历具有文化意识或敏感性，他们不仅能使用相同的语言，理解退伍军人在服役期间面临的一些术语或文化问题，这确实有助于在提供者和退伍军人之间建立更好的治疗关系，从而使他们能够成功地参与治疗。
in an evidence-based therapy. And so there's been a lot of effort to try to increase cultural competence among veterans, or excuse me, among providers to veterans, particularly in mental health, so that they can not only speak the language, but understand and develop that sensitivity and empathy with some of the experiences that they have faced. And for women who have experienced sexual harassment or sexual assault, Even actually for some men, you know, while the rate of exposure to military sexual harassment and trauma may be lower for men, there are more men in the military. So the number of men who've experienced military sexual trauma is also high.
参与循证治疗。因此，人们付出了很多努力来提高退伍军人，或者说，提高退伍军人医疗服务提供者的文化胜任力，特别是在心理健康领域，这样他们不仅能使用相同的语言，还能理解并培养对退伍军人所经历的一些体验的敏感性和同理心。对于经历过性骚扰或性侵犯的女性，甚至实际上对于一些男性来说，你知道，虽然男性遭受军事性骚扰和创伤的比例可能较低，但军队中男性人数更多。因此，经历过军事性创伤的男性人数也很多。
And knowing to ask about these experiences is critically important to try to understand how that may be related to their current mental health conditions or problems, but also related to their risk for suicidal behavior. And with that cultural competency, I know it's very important in the minority populations to have mental health providers who have a deep understanding of their clients. And in this case, having a military background, I'm assuming it's probably would be very beneficial or at least a deep understanding of that. Are there enough psychologists today who you think have those backgrounds and understanding, you know, those these psychologists out there, are there enough who are working with veterans? Well, that's a great question. And, you know, I think it's important to disentangle, you know, whether it's just about having a military background or whether cultural competence can be gained by being exposed to and work. with the population. And so anybody who has worked even as a civilian with the military population or in the Department of Veterans Affairs we have found will score higher on criteria, you know,
了解并询问这些经历对于理解这可能与他们当前的心理健康状况或问题有何关联，以及与他们自杀行为的风险有何关联至关重要。有了这种文化胜任力，我知道在少数群体中，拥有深入了解其客户的心理健康提供者非常重要。在这种情况下，拥有军事背景，我认为这可能非常有益，或者至少是对其有深刻的理解。你认为今天是否有足够的心理学家具备这些背景和理解，你知道，那些心理学家，是否有足够多的人在与退伍军人合作？嗯，这是一个很好的问题。而且，你知道，我认为理清这一点很重要，你知道，这仅仅是关于拥有军事背景，还是可以通过接触和工作获得文化胜任力。与该群体合作。因此，我们发现，任何即使作为平民与退伍军人群体合作过，或在退伍军人事务部工作过的人，在标准上都会得分更高，你知道，
evaluating military cultural competence among the provider community. And there's been focused efforts, particularly for mental health, to increase cultural competency in mental health therapists more so than non-mental health therapists. But there's still not a lot of data to indicate that that cultural competency of the provider is tied to clinical outcomes. And so the theory is that it's about this cultural competency contributing to an enhanced therapeutic rapport, which is essential for treatment engagement and retention and adherence. And to treatment. And so the emphasis on, you know, training providers is important, but it's not just that a psychologist
评估提供者社区中的军事文化胜任力。目前已经有重点工作，特别是在心理健康领域，旨在提高心理健康治疗师的文化胜任力，这比非心理健康治疗师更受重视。但目前还没有太多数据表明提供者的文化胜任力与临床结果挂钩。因此，理论上认为，文化胜任力有助于增强治疗关系，这对于治疗的参与度、保持率和依从性至关重要。对于治疗而言。因此，强调培训提供者很重要，但这不仅仅是心理学家
or a mental health therapist has a military background, but that perhaps they've been exposed to and worked with the population and been trained about the experiences that the veteran community may have faced so that they're asking the right questions, listening and developing a good therapeutic relationship. And before we kind of move to another topic, Caitlin, I just wanted to highlight that for women veterans, we hear kind of time and time again in the research that the presumption that they're not veterans is really strong. So among in, you know, VA facilities when, you know, even non-clinical staff, when, you know,
或心理健康治疗师拥有军事背景，而是他们可能接触过并与该群体合作过，并接受过关于退伍军人群体可能面临的经历的培训，以便他们能提出正确的问题，倾听并建立良好的治疗关系。在我们转向另一个话题之前，凯特琳，我只想强调，对于女性退伍军人，我们在研究中一次又一次地听到，关于她们不是退伍军人的推定非常强烈。因此，在退伍军人事务部的设施中，你知道，即使是非临床工作人员，当，你知道，
the people checking them in, administrative support, you know, assumes that the woman is the veteran spouse, for example, can be very off-putting. And so I think that goes, you know, for community providers. I don't think, I don't know if we know to what extent community providers are making these assumptions or not. The research hasn't been done necessarily, but I think that that's really critical that, you know, the minute a woman veteran, or rather, I would rather say that cultural competency requires an understanding of the diversity of the veteran population and not making presumptions and just thinking through and allowing, you know, your implicit bias, recognizing your own potential implicit bias and correcting that.
办理入住手续的人员，行政支持人员，你知道，假设女性是退伍军人的配偶，例如，这可能会让人非常反感。所以我认为这同样适用于社区提供者。我不认为，我不知道我们是否知道社区提供者在多大程度上做出了这些假设。研究不一定做过，但我认为这非常关键，你知道，女性退伍军人一出现，或者我更愿意说，文化胜任力需要对退伍军人群体的多样性有理解，不要做出推定，只需思考并允许，你知道，你的隐性偏见，认识到你自己潜在的隐性偏见并加以纠正。
Yeah, I imagine that's very important. You said if someone's assuming that the woman is not the veteran, that's, you know, that's already setting you up for, you know, maybe a fragmented relationship or, you know, bringing up a lot of different issues that wouldn't be helpful later on. So there's a lot, so you're saying basically there's a lot that needs to be done in this area, but that having a deep understanding of the military, at least, and having that knowledge is beneficial to the, to the client in the, in the relationship. Yeah. And my discussions, you know, Terry has really helped me think through this. You know, I used to think about high quality care, like evidence,
是的，我想这非常重要。你说如果有人假设女性不是退伍军人，那，你知道，那已经为你设置了，你知道，可能是一种破碎的关系，或者，你知道，提出了许多不同的问题，这些问题在以后不会有帮助。所以有很多，所以你基本上是在说在这个领域需要做很多工作，但对军队有深刻的理解，至少，拥有这些知识对客户，在关系中是有益的。是的。在我的讨论中，你知道，特里真的帮助我思考了这个问题。你知道，我过去常把高质量护理看作是，比如证据，
like you're juggling, like providers are juggling two things, high quality care and, cultural competency and juggling those two. And Terry's really kind of convinced me and helped me understand that a part of high quality care is not just the delivery of evidence-based care, but also being culturally competent. So they're not two separate things. They're all kind of this umbrella of high-quality care. Right. Do you think in general there's a lot of stigma about veterans seeking mental health services? Do you think that's lessen today? I mean, in general, in the population, mental health stigma has decreased, but in the veteran population, is it decreasing? Is it the same? So, you know, I like to unpack that term stigma and really kind of
就像你在杂耍一样，就像提供者在同时处理两件事，高质量护理和文化胜任力，并在这两者之间取得平衡。特里真的说服了我，并帮助我理解了高质量护理的一部分不仅是提供循证护理，而且还要具备文化胜任力。所以它们不是两件分开的事情。它们都在高质量护理的保护伞下。对。你认为总体上退伍军人寻求心理健康服务是否存在很多污名？你认为今天这种情况有所减轻吗？我的意思是，总体而言，在人群中，心理健康污名已经减少，但在退伍军人群体中，它在减少吗？还是一样？所以，你知道，我喜欢拆解“污名”这个词，并真正地，你知道，
focus on the, you know, the phrase kind of barriers to care and what we know are obstacles and barriers to help seeking and the receipt of high quality care. And while certainly the attitudes that an individual has about help seeking and how they might be perceived are important, there are other barriers and repercussions from help seeking that are also critical for the veteran population. And this really is the fear of a negative career repercussion, that they could somehow be harmed in their career progression or career to. trajectory by getting mental health care. It could somehow affect their security clearance. And those are more highly endorsed among the military and veteran population than are the traditional
重点关注所谓的“护理障碍”，以及我们所知的阻碍寻求帮助和获得高质量护理的障碍。虽然个人对寻求帮助的态度以及他们可能如何被看待确实很重要，但对于退伍军人群体来说，寻求帮助所带来的其他障碍和后果也至关重要。这实际上是对职业负面影响的恐惧，即他们可能会因为接受心理健康护理而以某种方式损害其职业发展或职业轨迹。这可能会以某种方式影响他们的安全许可。在军队和退伍军人群体中，这些担忧比传统的
thoughts that, you know, you would be seen as weak by getting mental health care. And those consequences can be very real for some individuals. So we need to kind of focus on, you know, interventions that can decrease those obstacles and not necessarily just call it all stigma. I think that there's been a greater awareness and efforts to promote veterans to seek care when they need help. And the rates of help seeking among those who've served in the Post-on-11 era is about, you know, 50% of those who've experienced a mental health problem will have sought care for that problem. We would like to see it become higher. But again, it's about decreasing some of those barriers and not just overcoming what we traditionally think of as the stigma
认为接受心理健康护理会被视为软弱的想法得到了更广泛的认同。对于某些人来说，这些后果可能是非常真实的。因此，我们需要关注那些能够减少这些障碍的干预措施，而不一定只是将其统称为“污名化”。我认为，人们已经有了更高的意识，并努力促进退伍军人在需要帮助时寻求护理。在“9·11”后时代服役的人群中，寻求帮助的比率大约是50%，即那些经历过心理健康问题的人中，有一半会寻求护理。我们希望看到这个比例更高。但同样，关键在于减少其中的一些障碍，而不是仅仅克服我们传统上认为的与心理健康相关的污名化。
associated with mental health. That's so important. I love unpacking this term stigma. Two things. I do a lot of work on. So some people think, well, what does a security clearance matter if you're a veteran? You know, you're no longer in the military. It's not as important to have a security clearance. We have to look at the data and recognize that a lot of veterans are going into jobs that still require, you know, some of these clearances.
这非常重要。我喜欢剖析“污名化”这个词。有两件事我做了很多研究。有些人会想，如果你是一名退伍军人，安全许可有什么关系呢？你知道，你已经不在军队了。拥有安全许可不再那么重要了。我们必须查看数据并认识到，许多退伍军人正在从事仍然需要这些许可的工作。
I think, you know, all the ones, all the veterans who are going into work for the intelligence community, for law enforcement, first responder community. I mean, it's full of veterans. And so these concerns about the impact, the career repercussions for seeking mental health care are the same, or, you know, just it's the same version of the same coin. The other one that we hear about that I haven't seen as much attention on is kind of the diversity of treatment options. So we hear a lot, we've heard a lot that some veterans are really concerned about the side effects of different pharmacotherapy treatments. And so I think really just educating veterans and part of our, you know, quote unquote, anti-stigma campaigns needs to be about what actually mental health treatment is and that there are options and that it should be patient-centered and patient-directed. And if you want pharmacotherapy, then there's a number of different options that you can.
我想，所有进入情报界、执法部门、急救人员社区工作的退伍军人，到处都是退伍军人。因此，这些关于寻求心理健康护理对职业影响的担忧是一样的，或者说，这只是同一枚硬币的另一面。我们听到的另一个我没有看到太多关注的问题是治疗方案的多样性。我们听说很多退伍军人非常担心不同药物治疗的副作用。所以我认为，真正教育退伍军人，以及我们所谓的“反污名化”运动的一部分，需要关于心理健康治疗到底是什么，以及有很多选择，而且它应该是以患者为中心和以患者为导向的。如果你想要药物治疗，那么有很多不同的选择可以尝试。
try. And if you want, you know, psychotherapy, then there's, you know, really good high quality treatments. A lot of the ones that, you know, Terry already mentioned, like prolonged exposure or CPT, trauma-informed CPT. So I think that, you know, we really have to be, it's not just about, you know, getting people into care by telling them, you know, it's not a sign of weakness. While that's important, we have to be tackling these other angles, if you will, of stigma. Right. And the beliefs about the effectiveness of mental health care are really, important. And so, you know, we need to help veterans and others know that treatment can work and that there are effective therapies available and helping them to understand the options
如果你想要心理治疗，那么也有非常好的高质量治疗方法。特里已经提到的很多方法，比如延长暴露疗法（PE）或认知加工疗法（CPT）、创伤知情CPT。所以我认为，我们真的必须做到，不仅仅是通过告诉人们“这不是软弱的表现”来让他们接受护理。虽然这很重要，但我们必须解决这些其他方面的“污名化”。没错。关于心理健康护理有效性的信念非常重要。因此，我们需要帮助退伍军人和其他人知道治疗是有效的，并且有有效的疗法可用，帮助他们了解各种选择，
and to evaluate which ones are going to be most successful will be critical in making them more informed consumers and perhaps more confident that when they seek out to reach help, that they will be offered something that has the promise of relieving their symptoms and promoting recovery. What about the caregivers of veterans? I'm talking about spouses or family members who likely take on the everyday responsibilities of working with their family member or loved one with the physical or mental health wounds. Do they have enough resources and support? In short, I would say no, that they don't have enough resources yet available. to them. Fortunately, Terry and I actually collaborated and worked on a project together on America's
并评估哪些方案最成功，这对使他们成为更知情的消费者至关重要，也许能让他们在寻求帮助时更有信心，相信他们会得到有望缓解症状并促进康复的治疗。那么退伍军人的照护者呢？我说的是那些可能承担起照顾患有身心创伤的家人或亲人的日常责任的配偶或家庭成员。他们是否有足够的资源和支持？简而言之，我会说没有，他们目前还没有足够的资源。幸运的是，特里和我实际上合作了一个关于美国军事和退伍军人照护者的项目，名为“隐藏的英雄”（Hidden Heroes），我们在那里了解了很多关于这个群体的信息。如果我们关注“9·11”后的照护者群体，我们发现今天大约有110万美国成年人在照顾“9·11”后时代服役的人，其中约64%的人在照顾患有心理和行为健康挑战的人，而约40%的照护者本身符合抑郁症的标准。所以我认为我们必须考虑提供给他们的资源。但有时，资源是存在的，关键是确保照护者知道这些能够支持他们的资源。
military and veteran caregivers called Hidden Heroes, where we learned a lot about the population. And if we focus on that post-9-11 group of caregivers, we found that there's around 1.1 million American adults today who are caring for someone who served in post-9-11 era in the post-911 era, that around 64% of them are caring for someone for mental and behavioral health challenges, and that around 40% of those caregivers themselves meet criteria for depression. So I think we have to think about the resources that are available to them. But also, sometimes, you know, the resources exist, and it's ensuring caregivers know about those resources that are able to support them.
并让他们知道帮助是存在的。然后，至关重要的是确保这些资源及其可用性符合照护者的日程安排。他们的照护需求可能非常繁重。他们可能既要照顾家人，又要兼顾为人父母，还要工作。他们可能是有工作的。所以他们身兼数职。因此，朝九晚五的治疗或支持小组，即在朝九晚五时间表内发生的事情，可能对他们来说并不方便。
and letting them know that help exist. And then, you know, critically is then making sure that those resources and the availability of them fits with the caregiver's schedule. Their caregiving demands can be very difficult. They may be juggling caregiving as well as being a parent, as well as, you know, and being a worker. They may be employed. So they're carrying multiple hats. So nine to five treatments or support groups, you know, things that happen. from a 9 to 5 schedule may not work to their, you know, be conducive to them.
所以，如果资源存在，但由于他们的其他需求而无法获得，那么这对他们就没有多大帮助。因此，如果我们想支持这个群体，我们必须考虑如何最好地在他们所在的地方满足他们的需求，以便我们能够支持他们。但我实际上认为，那些患有精神疾病的人的家庭本身并不一定有足够的支持来照顾他们的亲人。特里，你有什么要补充的吗？
So if it's there, but they can't access it because of their other demands, then it doesn't do them much good. So we have to think if we want to support this group, how we can best kind of meet their needs wherever they are so that we can support them. But I actually think that the families of those people with mental illnesses themselves don't necessarily have adequate support. for caring for their loved ones. Terry, do you have anything to add?
嗯，我会补充说，考虑他们获得这些服务的资格和途径很重要，正如拉吉夫提到的，但他们中的许多人可能不符合许多照护者支持计划或现有服务的传统资格标准，因为他们可能是退伍军人的父母。而且，他们可能不符合某些传统的照护支持服务，或者他们是他们所照顾的退伍军人的朋友或邻居。因此，我们通常认为家庭照护者是配偶或子女。但我们知道，这同样是一个多元化的群体。它包括父母以及提供支持的朋友和邻居。
Well, I would add, you know, that it's important to think about their eligibility and access to these services, as Rajeev mentioned, but many of them, you know, may fall outside of the traditional eligibility criteria for a lot of caregiver support programs or the services that are available to them because they are the parents, for example, of the veteran. And, you know, they may not qualify for some of the traditional caregiving support services or they are the friend or neighbor of the veteran that they are caring for. And so we often think about family caregivers as the spouse or a child. But we know that, you know, this is, again, a diverse group. It includes parents as well as friends and neighbors who are providing that support.
因此，确保他们也能获得这些支持资源，因为他们也容易受到与照护相关的负担和压力的影响。是的，绝对是这样。特里，我们之前谈到了“道德伤害”的概念，我想在这里多谈一点，这基本上是指当某人违反了他们的道德准则并经历了持久的心理影响时的情况。你能多谈谈道德伤害这个概念以及它对退伍军人意味着什么吗？当然。我当然不是道德伤害研究方面的专家，但这是一个我们正在加深对该结构理解的领域，同时也看到了旨在解决这一问题的特定干预措施的发展。它确实触及了你提到的内容，即对个人信念的挑战，这些信念可能是基于文化、群体，或围绕宗教或精神信仰。当他们犯下违规行为或目睹了他人违规行为时，无论是故意还是无意，道德伤害就会发生，这以某种方式导致了这种困境。因此，当我们试图了解退伍军人面临的挑战时，临床医生和研究人员已经确定，道德
And so making sure that they also have access to those support resources because they too are vulnerable to the burdens and stress associated with caregiving. Yes, absolutely. Terry, we spoke earlier about the concept of moral injury, which I want to talk a little bit about here, which is basically when someone violates their moral code and they experience a lasting psychological impact. Can you talk more about moral injury of this concept and what it means for veterans? Sure. Certainly I'm not an expert in the study of moral injury, but it is an area where we're gaining a deeper understanding of the construct as well as seeing the development of some specific interventions that can try to address it. And it really does get at, you know, what you mentioned is, you know, a challenge to an individual's beliefs that may be culture-based or group-based or focused around religious or spiritual beliefs. and that a moral injury occurs when they've either committed an act of transgression or they've witnessed a transgressive act by another, whether purposefully or by mistake, and that this somehow causes this dilemma. And so as we're trying to understand the challenges that veterans face, you know, clinicians and researchers have identified, you know, moral
伤害是战斗经历和战争的结果，并看到这种内疚、羞耻和其他类型的现象与他们所说的道德伤害有关。这提出了真正不同类型的干预措施和方法，以帮助这些人克服其中的一些后果，使他们能够再次过上更少症状的生活，并恢复生活质量。是的，我也不是这方面的专家，但我会说我非常兴奋。我最近看到了很多研究，试图为非心理健康专业人士（如随军牧师或教牧咨询师）制定方案和循证治疗方法，试图触及道德伤害的其他维度。
injury is a consequence of combat experience and war and seeing that, you know, this guilt and shame and other kind of phenomenology is associated with what they're calling moral injury. And it suggests really different types of interventions and approaches to help those individuals overcome some of those consequences so that they, you know, can live, again, more symptom-free and regain a quality of life. Yeah, I'm not an expert on it either, but I will say I'm very excited. I've seen a lot of research recently that is trying to develop protocols and evidence-based treatments for non-mental health professionals like chaplains or pastoral
而且我看到了针对心理健康提供者的新型政策倡议，他们承认患者或个人的精神健康，并试图促进随军牧师与心理健康专业人员之间的合作，以便他们提供一致的信息，在不违反患者隐私的情况下，不产生冲突，但他们正在想办法共同努力，以解决潜在的抑郁症状以及特里刚才谈到的与道德伤害相关的内疚和羞耻感。总的来说，今天的战争，现代战争非常复杂。当然有在海外服役的部署人员，他们每天都生活在那样的现实中。但也有其他人驻扎在美国，但正在战区执行任务。所以，例如，一名无人机操作员可能就在华盛顿特区地区，打击阿富汗的一个城镇。
counselors that are attempting to get at some of these other dimensions of moral injury. and I've seen new kind of policy initiatives that for mental health providers that recognize their patients or an individual's kind of spiritual health and then try to foster kind of collaboration between a chaplain and the mental health professional so that they're kind of giving consistent messages, that they're not conflicting without, you know, of course, without violating the patient's privacy, but that they're kind of coming up with ways to, work together so that they're addressing, you know, potentially the depressive symptoms as well as some of the guilt and shame associated with moral injury that Terry was just talking about. And in general, today's warfare, modern warfare is very complex. There are deployed members who serve overseas, of course, and they live in that reality every day. But there are others who are based in the U.S., but who are performing duties in a war zone. So, you know, for example, a drone operator could be here in the Washington, D.C. area, strike a town in Afghanistan.
有些人远在数千英里之外。如果，例如，那次打击杀死了包括一些平民在内的人，那么操作员就会回家。你知道，他们回到他们所谓的“正常生活”，他们并不是每天都处于那种战争环境中。我想谈谈这种并置对一个人的心理健康有什么影响。我的意思是，当他们基本上在一天之内过着几乎是两种不同的生活时。这怎么……特里，你能详细说明一下吗？嗯，我可以再试一次。你知道，我不知道我们是否有足够的数据来真正理解其中的细微差别。
some are thousands of miles away. And if, for example, if that, that strike kills people, including some civilians, then the operator goes home. You know, they go back to their, quote, normal life and they're not in that war environment every single day. I want to talk about what that juxtaposition does to someone's mental health. I mean, when they're basically living almost, I guess I almost think of it as like living two different lives in one day. How does that, you know, Terry, can you elaborate on that a bit more? Well, I can try again. You know, I don't know that we have enough data to really understand the nuances
但如果我们把作为一个军事单位在战斗剧院部署的概念想一想，你知道，你作为一个单位与一个小组、小团队或大团队在一起，你专注于特定的任务。你不仅有可以“守望相助”的人，而且你还有一起经历这些的人，因此有机会进行处理。而且你还远离了家庭生活的压力，或者他们可能带来的一些干扰。
associated with it. But if we think about the concept of deploying as a military unit in a combat theater, you know, the idea that you're there as a unit with a group, small team or a large team, you're focused on a particular mission. And you have, you know, not only individuals to kind of, you know, watch your six or guard your back and you're there for a specific mission, but you have people that you're experiencing it with, and so an opportunity to process. And you're also away from the stressors of home life or, you know, some of the distractions that they can introduce.
对于那些可能在美国本土执行支持职能或战斗角色，然后回家吃晚饭、那天晚上帮忙做家庭作业或承担一些家务责任的人来说，这些可能不一定存在。因此，必须理解这两个不同的世界可能会给一些人带来挑战，但这也可能帮助他们缓解压力，并能够关注其他事情，而不必纠结于他们白天做了什么。因此，我认为在获得关于这些类型的操作员及其经历的更多数据，以及是什么导致了那些做得好的人和那些做得不太好的人的情况之前，理解其中的一些细微差别及其影响是不清楚的。
Those may not necessarily be present for individuals who are perhaps stateside, you know, and performing their support functions or, you know, combat rule. and then going home and having dinner to help with homework that night or, you know, take on some of the household responsibilities. And so, you know, having to make sense of those two different worlds can create challenges for some, but it also may help them mitigate and be able to, you know, pay attention to other things and not necessarily dwell on, you know, what they did during the day. And so it's unclear I think, you know, understanding some of the nuances and what its impact might be until we gain, you know, more data on those types of operators and the experiences that they have and what contributes to those that
我们所做的其他一些研究着眼于部署对军人家庭的影响，我们知道与家中的配偶沟通可以起到保护作用，并且帮助管理关于军人在部署期间如何维持与家人的关系，可以在长期影响中发挥保护作用。因此，当个人没有被部署到战区，而只是每天去上班然后回家时，这种家庭沟通如何得到支持？拉吉夫，你对此有什么补充吗？我觉得这太关键了。我觉得特里说得很好。
do well and those that don't do so well. And some other work that we've done looking at the impact of deployment on military families, we know that communication with the spouse at home can be protective and, you know, helping to manage the expectations about how a service member maintains that relationship with their family while they're deployed can have a protective role in the impact long term. And so, you know, how does that family communication get supported when the, you know, the, you know, individual isn't deployed? to a combat zone, but is only, you know, going to their job and then home every day. Rejeeve, do you have anything to add on this topic? I just think it's so critical. I think that what Terry said is great.
我只是觉得这需要进行更好的研究。正如我之前所说，我做了很多关于执法人员自杀的研究。当我们交谈时，我们最近做了一项研究，采访了美国各地的120多个执法机构。我们专注于警官。但当我们问他们“你还关心谁”时，他们总是会说调度员。
And I just think it needs to be researched so much better. As I said earlier, I do a lot of work on law enforcement suicide. And when we were talking, you know, we just interviewed, we did a study recently where we interviewed over around 120 law enforcement agencies across the United States. And we were focused on the officers. But when we asked them, you know, who else in your, you know, who else who works for Hugh are you concerned about? And they would always say the dispatch operators.
我有点，也许这不相似。也许是。但他们是在电话上接到关于危机的电话，然后派遣某人的人。他们往往不一定看到结果发生了什么，但这是一个高压环境。而且，他们也回家，回到他们的家中，通常不被认为是警官。但我认为有很多工作是非常有压力的，以我们过去没有假设的方式。
And I kind of, maybe it's not similar. Maybe it is. But they're kind of on the phones who are getting called about this crisis and then dispatching someone. And oftentimes they don't see necessarily what happens as a result, but it's a high stress environment. And, you know, they too go home and, you know, to their homes and things of that nature and often aren't considered officers. But it's a very, I think there's a lot of jobs out there that are very stressful in ways that we haven't kind of assumed in the past.
我们需要真正拓宽我们的视野，考虑人们在日常生活中所经历的不同压力。没错。绝对是这样。然后考虑这对我们为他们提供支持资源的不同方式意味着什么，无论是促进额外的资源还是干预机会，这都非常关键，因为这可能是一个我们需要完全不同的模式。是的，关于其中一些工作，也许不像前线那样，但它们有助于帮助人们、急救人员等，这真的很迷人。这听起来确实是一个非常迷人的研究领域，正如你所说，需要进一步探索。
And we need to, like, really open our aperture for lack of a better term and think about the different stressors that people are experiencing on a day-to-day basis. Right. And absolutely. And think about then what that suggests for different ways that we put in support resources for them, whether it be, facilitating, you know, additional resources or opportunities for interventions is really critical because it could be a totally different model that we need. Yeah, that's really fascinating about some of these jobs that maybe aren't like the front lines, but they're contributing to, you know, helping people, first responders, that sort of thing. And that just sounds like a really fascinating area of research, like, as you said, that needs to be explored more.
那么，与过去相比，你在当今战争方式中看到的其他一些复杂性及其对退伍军人心理健康的影响是什么？所以，我的意思是，这是一个完美的铺垫，因为正如特里和我在播客开始时谈到的战斗暴露及其对随后创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的风险，有些人认为这在军队中，你有一个战斗角色或战斗支持角色。但这些区别不再一定与一个人的战斗暴露有关，因为你可以在阿富汗高度安全的环境中成为一名卡车司机。你是一名卡车司机。
What about some of the other complexities you see in the way wars are fought today and those effects on veterans' mental health as compared to the past? So, I mean, that's a perfect setup because and what we were just talking about, I think when Terry and I at the beginning of the podcast we were talking about, you know, the combat exposure and its risk on, you know, subsequent PTSD, some people think of that as kind of, you know, in the military, you have a combat role. or a combat support rule. But those distinctions don't necessarily relate anymore to a person's combat exposure because you can be a truck driver in the heightened, you know, the heightened kind of security climate in Afghanistan. You're a truck driver.
你知道，当简易爆炸装置（IED）是一个巨大的威胁时，你本质上是在提供支持，但你可能每天都在经历战斗。所以正如你所说的，现代战争，我们必须考虑这些暴露，然后考虑我们如何衡量人们在做什么以及他们正在经历的风险。我认为IED战斗支持角色是现代战争正在改变的一个主要例子。我们必须再次抛弃我们对战斗暴露的假设，以及
You know, when IEDs are a huge threat, you know, you're essentially providing support, but you could be experiencing combat day to day. And so exactly where you're saying, you know, modern warfare and kind of we have to think about these exposures and then think about how we're measuring, you know, what people are doing and the risks that they're experiencing. And I think the IED kind of combat support role is a prime example of the ways that modern warfare is changing. And we have to kind of, again, throughout our assumptions of what exposure to combat and
我们最有可能在哪里看到这种情况，哪些职业最有可能看到这种情况。没错。紧接着这一点，不仅是暴露于这些非常具有威胁性的经历和创伤性经历，即使是对于战斗支持角色，而且只是对暴露于创伤性脑损伤（TBI）的理解，以及这些后果可能意味着什么，特别是来自爆炸暴露。我们仍在更多地了解爆炸暴露对大脑的影响，以及退伍军人可能经历的一些短期和长期后果。我的意思是，我认为，常见的说法是
where we're most likely to see that, what occupations were most likely to see that. Right. And just a follow on of that, not only, you know, the exposure to the these very threatening experiences and traumatic experiences for even combat support roles, but just the understanding of being exposed to a traumatic brain injury and what those consequences can mean, particularly from blast exposures. We're still learning more about the effects of blast exposure on the brain and some of the short and long-term consequences that may be experienced by veterans who have traumatic brain injury. I mean, I think, you know, the common lure that
这只是脑震荡，症状会消退，这对于我们一些有重复暴露和重复脑损伤的退伍军人来说可能不一定成立，而且症状可能与创伤后应激障碍或抑郁症重叠，真正试图理清并理解我们如何为头痛和注意力困难等问题提供适当有效的治疗。我们不能仅仅假设这一切都与经历创伤后应激障碍有关，而是其中一些可能是由于脑损伤本身和爆炸暴露引起的大脑变化的结果。因此，这确实改变了我们需要在评估方面更加勤奋的方式，
this is just a concussion and the symptoms are going to reside may not necessarily hold true for some of our veterans who've had repeat exposures and repeat brain injuries and with the symptoms that can overlap with post-traumatic stress disorder or depression, really trying to disentangle and understand how do we provide appropriate effective treatment for things like headache and concentration difficulties. We can't just assume that it's all, you know, associated with experiencing post-traumatic stress disorder, but that some of it may be, you know, as a result of changes in the brain from the brain injury itself and that blast exposure. And so that's really changed the way that we need to be more diligent in how we assess
评估出现这些症状的退伍军人，并确保我们不仅是在做症状的自我报告，而且还要考虑成像，或者获取他们大脑的图像，了解可能正在发生什么。这可能还需要独立或并发的干预措施。在本次播客中，我们涵盖了一些相当沉重的话题。所以我想以一个更积极的基调结束。但我首先想问的问题是，你们两位能否谈谈在服役后寻找意义的重要性？我相信当人们离开像军队这样有意义的地方，然后进入平民生活时，这是一个巨大的转变。寻找一种新的意义有多重要，或者说，当你离开服役时，它会如何改变？
veterans who present with these symptoms and making sure that we're not just doing self-report of the symptoms, but also thinking about, you know, images or, you know, getting images of their brain and understanding what may be happening. That could also require independent or concurrent interventions. And during this podcast, we've covered some pretty heavy topic. So I want to end going on more of a high note here. But the first question I want to ask is, is the, can you both speak to the importance of finding meaning after military service? I'm sure that's a big transition that happens when people leave something like the military where you have this meaning and then you go into civilian life. And how important is it to find a new sort of meaning or, you know, as it changes as you leave service?
你知道，我认为人们非常关注确保军人在过渡时保持他们的目标感、使命感和承诺。我们知道，总的来说，退伍军人比非退伍军人更积极地参与公民事务和社区活动。因此，他们是使命驱动、目标驱动的个人。因此，帮助退伍军人理解，虽然他们的军事使命可能已经完成，但他们还有许多其他使命和目标可以实现。无论是寻找有意义的工作，还是在社区中发挥领导作用，或者与家人重新建立联系，我们已经看到许多关注“9·11”后退伍军人群体的亲和团体，他们真正致力于帮助退伍军人在回到家乡并融入社区后参与进来并找到那些新的机会。
You know, I think there's a lot of focus on ensuring that service members as they transition, you know, maintain their sense of purpose and mission and commitment. And we know that by and large, you know, veterans are more engaged civically and in their communities than non-veterans. And so they are mission-driven, purpose, you know, driven individuals. And so helping veterans to understand that while their military mission may be done, there are many other, you know, missions and purposes that they fulfill. And, you know, whether it be finding meaningful employment or leadership within their communities or, you know, reconnecting with their families, we've seen a lot of affinity groups that focus on this post on 11 veteran population that are really oriented. around helping veterans get engaged and, you know, find those new opportunities once they are back home and integrated within their communities.
拉吉夫，你想对此多说一点吗？当然。我只想说，也许这反映了我自己中年人的心态。但是，我认为寻找意义真的很难。当你谈到让退伍军人寻找意义时，这可能在某种程度上是存在主义的，可能非常有挑战性，这对退伍军人来说要求太高了。所以我认为，作为退伍军人，我们真正需要关注的是确保非退伍军人真正认识到退伍军人的价值。
Rejeev, do you want to elaborate on that a bit more? Sure. I'll just, you know, I'll say that, you know, maybe it reflects, you know, my own kind of middle-agedness. But, you know, I think finding meaning is really hard. When you say, like, you know, having veterans find meaning, that can be, you know, somewhat existential and can be very challenging to do, and it's a lot to place on a veteran. So I kind of think, you know, as a veterans where we really need to focus is ensuring that non-veterans really, as we've been talking about, really recognize the value of veterans.
他们举起右手服役，在非常具有挑战性的时期和非常具有挑战性的气候中，担任着非常不同的角色。我认为，非退伍军人有责任提高他们对退伍军人所做贡献的认识和认可。所以我很想，我认为通过这样做，并不是所有的意义都要由退伍军人自己去寻找，他们会找到意义的。如果我们欣赏他们的服役，那么我希望意义会随之而来。但我确实认为这是一个关键的角色，也是我们作为一个社会真正需要关注的事情。
They're, you know, how civic, they raised their right hand and served and served, you know, very challenging kind of times and a very challenging climates with very different roles. and I think, you know, it's incumbent upon the non-veterans to actually increase their awareness and recognition of the contributions veterans have made. So I would love to kind of, and I think by doing that, you know, it's not all on the veteran to find meaning, that they'll find meaning. If we appreciate their service, then the meaning, I hope, will come from that. But I do think it's a critical role in something that as a society we really need to focus on.
这就是退伍军人节的意义所在。这就是它的全部内容。这是关于我们非退伍军人认识到退伍军人所扮演的角色。是的，绝对是这样。这是一个结束这个问题的绝妙方式。总的来说，我还想以另一个基调结束。你们是否看到退伍军人的整体护理有所改善？我们已经谈了很多关于差距在哪里。
And that's the beauty of veterans day. That's what it's all about. It's about us kind of non-veterans recognizing the role that veterans have played. Yeah, absolutely. That's a wonderful way to end that question. And overall, I just want to end this one other note too. Are you seeing improvements in the overall care of our veterans? We've talked a lot about where those gaps are.
但你们真正看到退伍军人护理做得好的领域有哪些？我看到，我实际上已经看到我们正在交谈。我不知道这是否属实，但过去这是一个关于获得心理健康护理的问题。我认为我们正在看到人们的意识提高，不仅仅是获得心理健康护理，而是获得高质量的护理。我认为许多组织正在努力提高我们的心理健康护理专业人员提供真正高质量循证护理的能力。我认为我们还有很长的路要走。别误会我的意思，但我确实认为人们对这些问题有了很多认识，心理健康界也认识到提供高质量循证护理的必要性。
But what are some of the areas you're really seeing are care of veterans going well? I see that I actually have seen that we are talking. I maybe, I don't know if this is true, but it used to be a question about access to mental health care stop. And I think that we are seeing increased awareness as not just access to mental health care, but access to high quality care. And I think a lot of organizations are trying to increase the capacity of our mental health care professionals to do. deliver really high quality evidence-based care. And that's really, I think that we still have a long way to go. Don't get me wrong, but I do think that there's been a lot of awareness about these issues, as well as in the mental health community about the necessity for delivering high-quality evidence-based
是的，绝对是这样。而且我认为，我们当然看到了联邦政府在资金方面的大量投入，用于国防部和退伍军人事务部，以扩大他们的临床服务，同时也投资于研究。因此，这个机会使我们能够获得更多的见解，并在我们如何不仅在改进诊断方面进行诊断，而且在如何考虑甚至迈向精准医学以治疗创伤后应激障碍方面变得更加精确。因此，我们最终可以更好地将退伍军人与特定类型的有效治疗相匹配，基于对谁会对哪种类型的治疗反应最好的日益增长的科学基础。
care. Yeah, absolutely. And I think, you know, we've seen certainly large investments from the federal government in dollars for both the Department of Defense and the Department of Veterans Affairs to expand their clinical services, but also to invest in research. And so that opportunity is affording us even more insights in becoming more precise with how we can not just diagnose in terms of improved diagnostics, but how we can think about even getting towards precision medicine for the treatment of post-traumatic stress disorder. So we can do a better job in the end of matching veterans to particular types of efficacious treatments, you know, based upon an increasing and burgeoning scientific base for understanding who's going to respond to which types of treatments
所以，正如拉吉夫所说，这不仅仅是增加了获得高质量护理的机会，我们在那方面取得了重要的进展，而且增加了我们根据我们知道对他们有效的特定循证治疗来匹配退伍军人的机会。所以我在这方面看到了希望。我们需要继续资助心理健康状况的研究。我的意思是，我只是认为这是一种日益增长的意识。我们需要更多的循证方案。我认为我们现有的那些很好，让我们继续努力，争取更多。非常感谢你们参加这个非常重要的话题。我非常感谢你们的时间，我相信我们的听众会非常喜欢这一集。谢谢你们邀请我们。是的，谢谢。
best. And so it's not just increased access to high quality care is, as Rajiv said, we've made important headway in that, but increasing the opportunity we have to match veterans to specific evidence-based treatments that we know will work for them. So I see hope on the horizon, on the horizon in that regard. And we need to keep funding research on mental health conditions. I mean, I just think it's an increasing awareness. We need more. evidence-based protocols. I think the ones that we have are great and let's, you know, keep it going with more. Thank you so much for joining us on this very important topic. I really appreciate your time and I think our listeners will really enjoy this episode. Thank you for having us. Yeah, thank you.
这太棒了。在我们离开之前，我只想让你们知道，我们想听听你们的声音。你们可以将评论和想法通过电子邮件发送到 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speakingofpsychology，全部连在一起。org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。Speaking of Psychology 是 APA 播客网络的一部分，其中包括关于新心理学研究的 APA 期刊对话，以及关于心理学实践的进展笔记。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
This is great. And before we go, I just want to let you know that we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word.org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcast. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这太棒了。在我们离开之前，我只想让你知道我们想听听你的意见。你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speaking of psychology，所有单词连在一起.org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。Speaking of Psychology 是 APA 播客网络的一部分，其中包括关于新心理学研究的 APA 期刊对话，以及关于心理学实践的进度说明。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。